Carrie wrote in it's very popular for
some on the right or the classical
liberals or those people who talk about
equality of opportunity no I'm reading
this incorrectly what I mean is it's let
me start over
Carrie wrote in it's very popular for
some on the right or the classical
liberals to talk about equality of
opportunity as if it's the fairest way
to organize society but is it and what
does it actually mean I like this
question it has become popular for some
of these internet classical liberals to
talk about I'm for equality of
opportunity but you're never going to
have equality of outcome unless you take
away freedom because naturally not
everybody is going to do equally well in
any particular area I agree with that I
agree with that I actually think that
it's important for us to have equality
of opportunity
you can't force equality of outcomes
there is going to be a distribution of
how people do in any particular area
economically educationally whatever but
there's a few confusions in there right
number one is a lot of the people saying
they want equality of opportunity don't
actually understand that equality of
potential is not the same as equality of
opportunity you can imagine two people
one born in poverty to a chaotic home
life one born to a wealthy family with
tutors and blah-blah-blah-blah-blah
at birth we might identify imagine that
we could identify that genetically to
the extent that this is this is nature
versus nurture these two individuals had
the exact potential they had equality of
potential given that they were presented
with the right opportunity but part of
the opportunity comes from not being
born into poverty and being born into
more privileged situations so I agree
with the classical liberals that we
should be for equality of opportunity I
disagree about their definition about
equality of opportunity and
sometimes in order to equalize
opportunity does require some
interventions that could be from the
government or from others so
conceptually I totally agree with it I
just think they're wrong about how they
define equality of opportunity yeah I'm
thinking about it from a messaging point
of view so Republicans they have less
government stronger military Family
Values very basic things yep
and maybe this is one that Democrats can
champion equality of opportunity but
it's not the best messaging in a sense
because you don't strictly adhere to it
right I mean if you want strong public
schools that feels like it's equality of
opportunity and yet people will still be
able to afford private schools yes same
thing with health care if you if you
give that to everyone some people will
be able to spend more and get better
care sure
so is it completely equality of
opportunity no and maybe that's there's
some holes there I don't know this is
that what you're basically pointing out
is that there's this spectrum that
exists where on one hand you have total
freedom and on the other side you have
total equality the only way to have
total equality of outcomes is at the
expense of freedom and there's different
types of freedom the only way to have
total freedom
like really total unmitigated freedom is
that the absolute expense of any kind of
equality I don't think taxes on the
strong man with the with the weapons
takes everything I break the so as a
society it's lovely to talk about our
principles and the ballot ideas and say
I'm for freedom and equality of
opportunity and turn up your nose like
you figured out some magical combination
of principles the truth is we're all on
a spectrum somewhere between there and
the difference between a Scandinavian
democracy and a dictatorial of African
nation and Chile and the United States
neither is at either extreme and it's a
question of we're in the middle do we
want to be and it's a conversation we
have to have there's no way to just say
in an absolutist way this is the this is
the principle I adhere to on equality
versus freedom and there's no difficult
questions to figure out
I agree with everything you just said
that yeah I'm just
talking about you have to appeal to some
independent voters yes sure and when
Republicans are able to boil down their
ideas into these simple it's easy to
understand phrases yep it's very very
hard to compete with it's like else you
know even liberals will talk about
income equality right you're not
actually talking about you everyone
getting the same paycheck now it's hard
for people to rationalize yeah and this
is where the Republicans win on a lot of
issues right like hey abortion is murder
period simple super easy no abortions
the opposite from Democrats is not
abortion is great kill everybody right
it's much more complex yeah and so on a
lot of these issues there's just like a
structural a linguistic advantage as Pat
is pointing out to the right